ah now this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
why because we challenge them yeah to
try and find us making one tiny mistake
on this show right so far
millions of challengers not one winner
we are flawless we don't make mistakes
like our beard work
[Applause]
you and I should talk later about oh
okay supporting oh well tonight a young
fan named Pete the Panda thinks he
caught a mistake he says it happened
during an interview recently with Adam
Scott take a look
Conan you sir are dead wrong or at least
your sound effects famous because I
found a little mistake it's deceptive
that's that's 90 feet oh whoa we we lost
power Adam this has never happened
before during an interview you put a
sound effect in of a light bulb when the
power goes out there isn't a sound the
power just turns off you have to back
this up I want to talk to the first
person I know my dad is there somewhere
the power goes out no my dad says that
you're wrong gonna nice Lee is really
smart
okay is that is very smart but not does
not expend a lot of Anna know when he
lays down the truth but I like that kid
yeah I like Pete the Panda and I'm sorry
to tell you Pete but you are you are
wrong and I'm really sorry to say so was
your father Pete the Panda senior you
see citywide blackouts always make a
light bulb popping sound that is a
scientific fact and I can prove it
here's amateur video taken right before
last year's blackout in San Francisco
[Music]
here's footage from Paris's blackout
luckily blue and 1977 New York yeah yo
y'all hear that popping sound so that
just proves it and to prove it once and
for all
I asked the smartest person I know my
dad dad is Pete the Panda right No thank
you Dad
all right dad are you ever gonna say you
love me
[Applause]
so town still stands if you think you've
spotted an error on our reporter team
koco.com / how I found an error we will
sort it out right here on the air let's
see if you've got what it takes to make
chunk meat out of the maestro
you